he's worth five billion dollars and
turns 90 this year but stepford Heine is
not one to sit back and relax
billionaires by islands others pledged
their fortune to charity
some even run for president stepford
timer plans to put his portrait towards
an even higher purpose bringing peace to
Israel and its neighbors by fostering
industry and jobs to do this he spent
millions building industrial parks like
this one in Nazareth it's a story of all
people living together if people are too
busy working and earning money he
reasons they won't have time to fight
copy Switzerland
copy Germany copy South Korea and then
you have peas in this area it's a
sentiment shared by Ahmad Yunus whose
company moved to the Nazareth Park and
makes electrodes for treating
neurological disorders I wouldn't love
that if we had like 10 steps I think we
can change Israel thoughtfully the
latest eruption of violence would
suggest it'll take more than that more
than 25 Israelis and around 160
Palestinians most of them assailants
have been killed since October at the
tiffin industrial park over timers
vision has been working for 30 years he
lords industries like soap making and
metalworking even more than the startups
for which Israel has become famous and
main thing is that we should make the
product and not only and invented
left Rd and more export-oriented
products so it would create more job for
their timer who still eats with workers
at his car's canteen it's also personal
I have a special mission to feed that I
will stay here and be happy here and not
have to wander around like my parents
from Germany after 200 years of staying
there so I just continue to do the same
job I did 80 years ago and so Israel's
third richest man will keep building
industrial parks his next one is planned
for the southern desert aimed at the
country's bed winds and you've got Kim
Bloomberg News northern Israel